un camp sans trop de réactions il est
21h quand les premières estimations
arrive laurent saint martin est annoncé
avec 12% des voix le candidat tête de
liste la république en marche est
longuement restée que ses proches
collaborateurs et colistiers avant
d'annoncer se maintenir au second tour
invité tous ceux qui ne veulent pas se
retrouver dans un match entre la
présidente sortante une gauche réunie
qui veut sa revanche et l'extrême droite
oui il y à la place dans notre région il
doit y avoir la place dans notre région
pour les valeurs progressistes que prône
la majorité présidentielle ce soir la
vraie leçon c'est que la majorité
présidentielle sera présente dans
l'hémicycle régional pour les six
prochaines années
nous en sommes fiers et nous comptons le
porter avec ardeur avec conviction avec
détermination et sincérité ce qui fait
notre marque de fabrique depuis le début
de cette campagne dans les yvelines la
liste fait à peine mieux elle se hisse à
la troisième place à nouveau derrière
valérie pécresse et jordan bardella la
liste menée par le duo de députés jean
noël barrot et aurore bergé recueille un
peu plus de 12% des suffrages
on a une vraie force militante violents
se sont battus parce que ils croient
encore une fois que nos idées ils ont du
sens et que ça mérite tout simplement
qu'on puisse se battre pour aller c'est
vrai qu'on fait mieux dans les yvelines
que ce qu'on fait au niveau national
parce qu'on fait au niveau régional voit
dans le sud des yvelines ont fait encore
mieux que dans le département donc ça
veut dire aussi que quand quand on
travaille tout simplement qu'on
affrontait les franciliens les aubinois
voit qu'on on est en permanence à leurs
côtés pour se battre pour eux eh bien on
a de meilleurs résultats
on est là dans une élection qui est une
élection proportionnelle
on a une sortante qui réalise un score
élevé au premier tour qui vit qui va
très certainement l'emporter ce qui ne
doit pas empêcher toutes celles et ceux
qui se reconnaissent dans le projet que
nous avons porté pour l'ile-de-france
qui se reconnaissent dans l'action qui
est menée par le gouvernement dans
l'action qui est menée par le président
de la république d'exprimer ce sentiment
puisque notre projet c'est bien de
mettre en oeuvre ou en tout cas de
défendre les mêmes priorités à la région
sans réserve de voix la liste en ville
de france ne devrait pas pouvoir
augmenter son score avec une inconnue
pour le 27 juin l'abstention
au premier tour elle était de 69 % dans
les yvelines 2 66%